es tres menos cuatro una solución a la
ecuación 5 x 2 igual a 7
nos están preguntando si x igual a 3 y
menos 4 cumplen con esta ecuación
cumplen con esta relación que tenemos lo
que vamos a hacer entonces es sustituir
x igual a 3 igual a menos 4 en esta
ecuación y ver si efectivamente 5 x + 2
es igual a 7 tenemos entonces que cinco
por tres más dos por menos cuatro esto
es igual a 5 por 3 15 más 2 por menos 4
+ menos 8 y esto es efectivamente igual
a 7 así es que si es una solución ese
punto está en la recta x 3 y ya igual a
menos 4 efectivamente satisfacen esta
ecuación hemos respondido a la pregunta
si es solución otra manera de hacer esto
no voy a entrar en los detalles pero lo
que puedes hacer de hecho es graficar la
línea supongamos que la línea fuera algo
así no entra en los detalles pero lo que
tendrías que hacer es ver si el punto se
ubica sobre la línea si el punto
efectivamente está sobre la línea es una
solución y si no está sobre la línea no
es una solución pero para
esto tienes que ser un dibujo muy
preciso y así determinar si
efectivamente el punto está sobre la
línea si usas el método de sustitución y
al sustituir los valores en la ecuación
verificas que hay una validez matemática
en dicha ecuación esto es un método
preciso esto era lo que necesitábamos
hacer todo lo que necesitábamos hacer en
este ejemplo para verificar que
efectivamente si es una solución